make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with another
installment of our beyond omega level
series where we break down the origins
powers and feats of the strongest
characters in comics and this week we're
focusing on one of the most powerful
villains to ever plague
asgard sirder so sirder or at least the
marvel version of surter was created by
stan lee and jack kirby and first
appeared in journey into mystery number
97 in 1963 but like most characters in
the thor mythos he's based
on a norse myth certain belongs to a
race known as the fire giants who hail
from the realm of muspelheim and at some
unknown point came to be the ruler of
that realm in his earliest appearances
we see certain has been imprisoned by
odin as a punishment for attempting to
destroy the world now he's later
released from his imprisonment by loki
and subsequently
invades earth along with a storm giant
called skag it takes the combined forces
of odin and his sons thor and balder to
repel the invasion and odin is
significantly weakened in the process
and so at the end of the conflict
certain is imprisoned once again this
time
being confined to a meteorite in another
galaxy now certain
is best known for being one of the
entities that brings about ragnarok or
the destruction of asgard a process that
is repeated several times throughout
history as asgard is destroyed and
subsequently rebuilt
and we learned that in his first
encounter with odin certain was
approached by odin and his brothers vili
and v
upon learning that certain planned on
destroying their world with the twilight
sword and eternal flame of destruction
odin proposes destroying both weapons
which predictably does not sit well with
certain who sends his demonic minions to
attack the three brothers who merge into
one entity to battle certain now they're
unable to defeat certain but they do
manage to destroy the sword and steal
the brazier containing the eternal flame
and so after the brothers return to
their original form only odin is able to
escape
and vili and v are killed by surtr but
as they die they transfer their power to
odin and so sirder
is actually a key figure in odin
becoming as powerful as he is as the
transfer of power
led to the creation of what we call the
odin force now sirder
is over 1 000 feet tall and possesses
immense strength and durability
proving to be of much greater strength
than thor he was also capable of picking
up the black
pyramid which serves as a base of
operations for the egyptian god seth
and throw it without any difficulty when
soda came to earth he was strong enough
to remove a large chunk from the center
of the planet
and send it into orbit where he would
eventually become earth's moon
furthermore
serter is referred to as a breaker of
stars and the swings of his hammer as he
works in his forge
send reverberations that are felt in a
billion billion worlds now in terms of
durability it's nearly impossible to
deal any meaningful damage to certain
strikes from thor who's generally
regarded not only as the strongest
asgardian but one of the strongest
characters in the marvel universe do not
face certain
even when thor's wielding one of the
universe's most powerful weapons and his
hammer mjolnir
even thor odin and loki working together
were only able to temporarily slow
down surter and stutter not only
survived being hit with a planet-sized
object hurled it in by thor but was able
to produce enough heat to melt it
instantaneously he's able to endure
massive amounts of heat having survived
in a sea of flames and was unharmed by
blasts of mystical energy from loki as
well as an attack from odin wielding a
powerful weapon called the scepter
supreme which the all father states
possesses incalculable power even the
strongest weapon in the asgardian
arsenal the cosmic cannon had no effect
when sorter was hit with its full
blast in addition to his strength and
durability surter seemingly never tires
from battle
as for a long time he was locked into
battle with odin that renewed itself
every day seemingly for eternity now as
a fire giant
surter also possesses the ability to
generate and manipulate massive amounts
of heat and fire the fire generated by
surter is enough to melt asgardian
buildings
and to cause the seas to boil and
evaporate certain flames have proven
capable of hurting powerful beings such
as thor
and he claims that he can create enough
energy to melt an entire galaxy
sorter also has the ability to
shapeshift and can increase his size to
such incredible proportions that he
dwarfs stars he's also proficient in
magic
and is able to summon and command
legions of incredibly powerful fire
demons
each of which can fly and manipulate
flames themselves but surter is not only
a formidable fighter but is also an
accomplished forger of powerful weaponry
his most significant achievement in
forging weapons is the completion of the
twilight sword
an incredibly powerful mystical blade
that greatly enhances certain strength
the twilight sword is around 500 feet in
length and is made from a metal found
only in the mines of muspelheim called
scabrite surter forged the sword in the
heart of the burning galaxy which was
home to the corbinites before being
destroyed by sirder and his forces
so that the energy from the galaxy could
be harnessed to forge the blade now for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with the corbinites they're an
extraterrestrial race the most famous of
which is beta ray build and the
destruction of their home world by
surter
is actually what caused bill to cross
paths with thor in the first place
as he was seeking revenge against
certain but going back to the twilight
sword it's an insanely powerful weapon
containing vast mystical energy
wielding the twilight sword certain was
able to destroy the rainbow bridge of
asgard and cut through one of odin's
blasts which produced shock waves felt
in
nine realms the sword also affords
sorter a great deal of protection from
attacks as it shields him from a blast
from thor
that likely would have killed sirder had
it landed the magical effects of the
sword were also strong enough to
neutralize odin's powers
which is no small feat given how
powerful of a deity odin actually is but
the most impressive feat surter has
pulled off with the twilight sword are
probably using it to slice through the
fabric of time and space to create a
portal to midgard and cutting through
the dimensional barriers that separate
asgard from muspelheim and so the sword
is able to tear through time
space and dimensional barriers which i
would say make it among the most
powerful weapons in all of marvel comics
however the sword's full potential is
not reached until it joined with the
eternal flame of destruction which is a
magical flame which as its name suggests
cannot be put out when the sword and the
flaming combine the result is a weapon
whose true power
is likely immeasurable but is at least
capable of bringing about the end of
asgard
so yeah sorter is definitely a character
that is well beyond omega level and he's
not only capable of destroying a world
but in fact
destined to do so not only is he
prophesized to bring about the end of
asgard but he was able to destroy the
entire cormanite home world and its
galaxy
in order to simply create a weapon but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comics
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like
and i will catch you all later peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
you